I'm in the Arctic Circle and the big  question for me is why the Great  Outdoors means different things to  different people  I'm more of the Great Indoors type of  guy  but I've agreed to explore what lies  outside my comfort zone  a world I've spent my whole life  avoiding whoa whoa whoa beautiful  mountain that's a volcano that's a  volcano I think I'm feeling a heart  attack coming on I'm not entirely sure  what I signed up for but what's the  worst that can happen  um my God first time I've had my hand up  an elephant  [Music]  I like to avoid violence at all costs  how are you doing over there not bad  I'll be open  the open momentarily just surviving  would be great  you need some help no I got it  there is a world outside the resort  it's really important nature  family the friends that I met I'm going  for it let the screaming begin oh my God  oh my God oh my God  this is the last time I had five vodkas  with a fin  [Music]